probablement que la raison du
confinement n'est pas une raison
sanitaire eux et si on met ça en rapport
avec le fait que c'est pas seulement en
france 2 ça se passe parce qu'on
pourrait dire ça c'est macron il est fou
un bref peu importe ça se passe
mondialement c'est quasiment le monde
entier en tout cas les pays riches qui
dès qu'on gêne et donc le fait de mettre
ces deux choses ensemble c'est-à-dire un
confinement dont la raison n'est
probablement pas sanitaire parce que ce
virus est pas assez guide mais dangereux
et le fait que ça se passe mondialement
ça nous permet d'essayer de raisonner en
termes de système mais les dieux sont
contents de vous interrompre franck
lepage mais on pourrait tout aussi bien
dire que les deux chiffres que vous avez
donnée sont si bas enfin s'il ya eu si
peu de morts c'est justement parce qu on
a confiné
si on n'avait pas confiné si on avait
laissé faire comme au temps de la grippe
de hong kong
il y aurait pas eu trente ou quarante
mille morts en france puis en aurait
peut-être eu trois cent mille ou quatre
cent mille voire plus je vous rappelle
que les populations fragiles
en france c'est plus de 20 millions de
gens donc c'est plus de 20 millions de
gens qui pourraient qui risquerait de
mourir si l attraper le corps et navires
us pas forcément puisqu'il y en a
beaucoup qui dit rice heureusement mais
elle n'aurait plus en mourir voilà on
pourrait dire que c'est grâce au
confinement concerne séné si bien tiré
c'est l'argument que sortira le
gouvernement c'est évident on ne saura
jamais la plupart des médecins un peu
sérieux ont l'air de dire qu' on ne peut
absolument pas n'y a pas d'étude qui
permet de dire que le confinement nini
le masque d'ailleurs ont revu le moindre
effet donc on peut pas répondre à cette
question on peut effectivement c'est
effectivement l'argument qui va nous
être opposés c'est de dire c'est grâce
au confinement qu'il ya eu finalement
pas tellement noir
[Musique]